[Music]
sometimes I just sit in this tiny chair
and look at wow it's where we're
homeworks and it's pretty fun as long
it's just a job you know it's a job that
Eric now were given Cartoon Network
designed the show and we applied online
I was known in Philadelphia for my I did
a one-man Marlon Brando show it's just
impression of him for about an hour and
a half didn't cut other stuff everyone
knows Godfather one too so every wife's
doing my bits it's not a humorous show
but for some reason people laugh I want
to get the cotton in there and it's a
good show it's not that it's not a great
show but it's a good show it's time for
Mary Eagle your products on one Oh Tom
what's going on
okay but having a lot of problems with
her last supplier oh well and maybe you
could just pinch this over the phone
guys excited yeah okay it feels good we
got actually we got a great commotion
going right now as a matter of fact
we're giving one free toner for Wow
every three that you buy how you get how
the hell do you afford that Tom these
are some nagels George Nagel did I'm a
new show that we have on HBO says go
magus this is Eric Wareheim
- hi here whoever is editing the show is
on asset why don't you use the moments
when my acting is good instead of the
moments that were like 1 2 3
you know like tell me we're a big
company we tell all around the world I
mean all the way all around right so how
tall are you Tom were you coming from
what studio yen I actually used to be a
famous model I shot up shot with like
Mario's Mario Testino
Bruce Weber's assistant yeah quite a
great what quite a career it's the
cat Tim Heinicke got me one of the few
presents that you really put some
thought into I also got me Stanley
Kubrick poster which is a cherished
possession of mine if it's in my home if
you could resurrect one dead famous
person things to star in a video
produced and directed by you who would
it be and
it's just like hey Tom with all the
companies we work for like step Al's
and Office Depot that is they're not
personal to us if we want to if you want
your business once you give us a
personal pitch why you're involved with
a company why you're passionate about
your toner okay yeah and what are you is
it possible to get a headshot I
definitely trying to get back into the
energetic I do I'm asking you a personal
question do you have hair underneath
your armpits yeah okay well just for the
photo Tom's shade that offer to hire
some kind of Photoshop expert to to get
that hair low because no one wants to
see a man Bush nowadays
[Music]
how'd you guys meet well Eric came to my
rich little show in New York a lot of
people get confused they think wool
isn't just don't you just do rich little
doing impressions no I do
rich little as himself and that's where
the twist becomes amigo I didn't know
that much about rich little yeah better
some but we don't need to speak to your
supervisor right now please does this
service Paul's gone awry okay he's
actually my supervisors actually in
Vegas today but Oh where's he staying
Marlon Brando you know for you two as a
gift to you because for you to be able
to work with him that's really sweet it
would be so fun to watch if you're so
great to see that chemist I don't know
if I could do it I mean having him right
next to a 1
yeah with the name of your agent again
gorgeous what are they called
gorebyss gorgeous international dude and
you guys are located in white Hollywood
well it's well swirling swirling but you
know do you know where lax is right and
so that area okay it's actually we're
located in the airport in the
International Terminal okay that way
easier when like these models come over
and when you know like Italian models
come over we can just deal with them
correctly without having to go through
customs okay mmm-hmm best good okay
just a friend of mine
my body type of guy I gotta say right
now it's a little more commercial based
you know I mean I really got us I got
some competition out there and I
realized that but my face really works
for me so I mean at my height my
shoulders and we're not going to look at
your physical body but a huge area and
where your ass line comes out of your
pants right so probably just called you
guys are trying to get me some like
Calvin Klein's that streaker desires
something that he was then but mine
would be my MJ Lake
in choreography
yeah